let me ask you a question what did you
think when jordan peterson said
you know divorce should be 100 out of
the question
oh that's right how do you process that
how do you process that yeah jordan
peterson said that no matter how bad
your marriage is you should stay married
for the sake of the kids essentially
advocating for the what nuclear family
is that is that 100 so even as miserable
as you are you're fighting you're not
having sex with your you know you're not
meant to be
at what point you say you know we tried
enough enough and at what age of the
kids okay
do you think no matter what you should
stay married i think that if you again
one of the reasons why i vetted myself
before i vetted my wife was because of
exactly that can i be faithful this
person because if i can't then i should
not be reproducing and starting a family
and building this huge
you know
world or my frame around all of this if
that one little point at that one
fundamental point can't be can't be
maintained so yes sex is the glue that
holds relationships together sex is the
glue that holds marriages together and
if that falls apart i mean you go look
at the statistics for uh sexless
marriages in the united states right now
it's like something like at least twenty
percent and a sexist marriage by the way
is like
ten times a year right like one uh like
once a month or you know and then skip
two months i think that's what you're
saying you should stay married even if
you're in a sex relationship i think
that once you're already in that um i
think it's very important to uh as far
as raising the children if you want to
build strong families now a lot of
people will disagree with me on that
because they'll say well you know i'm
not getting what i need out of the
relationship and it's usually the woman
that is saying that it's not so much the
man the men will will put up and
tolerate way more than women will when
it comes to like a bad marriage because
they have more to lose women are more
incentivized financially incentivized to
uh to file for divorce this is one of
the reasons why seventy percent of
divorces are initiated by women then you
get like social narratives like um like
what we call divorce porn which is like
eat pray love right or stella got a
groove back or uh just divorce him girl
he's not the one for you he was never
your soul mate you need to go run off to
jamaica and have a good time and find
your soul mate there after you divorce
pretty good movie but that's about it
it's divorce porn it's a fantasy for
women who are like who gets to the point
where they they settled on a guy who was
not the the the one was not their
soulmate you know the one that got away
was the guy who in their in their uh in
their college days
and they get you want to know why they
call it the seven year itch it's because
it's usually right around seven years
that women have that you know they
decide is he the best that i can do and
more and more certainly since the 70s
when the answer to that is no and to the
point where we can go build you know
very you know profitable franchises and
romance novels and narratives go look at
uh anything like netflix has is chock
full of those narratives fifty shades of
french shades it's like the biggest
thing fifty shades of grey by the way
remember fifty shades of grey was self
published
it was not like would put 200 errors in
the book yes and it sold 65 million
copies in the first like like year or
that what do you think what do you mean
a few errors oh it was self-published
the guy had like who's who's lose lose
loose loose like spelling errors it was
basically fan fiction but it was just
rewritten by uh el or el something or i
can't remember like 50 some year old was
it
late 40 i don't know how old she was but
she wasn't hit on a very popular
narrative because it's a fantasy it's
the fantasy of i'm gonna and it's a it's
a fantasy with a lot of commonalities in
it as well but you have to look at the
popularity of that i mean i remember in
you talk about church i remember church
women going have you read fifty shades
of grey i can't wait till the movie
comes out and it was all good in the
hood to be to be reading this the movie
sucked but the soundtrack
and you know what you know what pastors
of the arabic you know you know the
religious guys of the era did they say
oh it's a failure of men
it's a failure of men that we that we've
allowed this to happen with women or we
can't live up we can't measure up to
that and so we'll we're ready to
self-flagellate and blame ourselves for
those for
you know the
impulses so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you